i just watched a documentary on i think
it's called free climbing
he he climbed this insanely high cliff
with no gear and was just like i feel
like
people who do that and do these insane
long distance running
there's got to be something something's
a little weird there no offense or
anything
no you're totally right and i think uh i
try to so
hey that's a really interesting comment
actually because i think
i know that is true but it's easy to
normalize it i've totally normalized
running a hundred miles so sometimes
when
someone's talking to me maybe not even a
runner at all they're looking at me kind
of like i've got three heads coming out
of my neck because i'm talking about
running 100 miles as if it's like the
standard or the norm
welcome to episode 99 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with zach bitter
zach bitter
is kind of insane he's a low carb keto
long distance runner
seriously long distance ultra marathon
did you know there are people who run
for
days crazy why would you do that
we got into why people do that why he
has that diet
gross things i really didn't want to
know about long distance running his
upcoming
charity run pushing limits low carb keto
and ultra marathon running and more zach
has held the 100 mile
run time record and is a podcaster and
coach and marathon runner and a really
lovely guy
i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
zack bitter welcome to my podcast hey
thanks for having me on mikayla
this should be a good conversation i
haven't talked to you since i was on
your podcast right yeah yeah i'm trying
to remember when that was
you were i think one of the fairly early
guests that that shawn and i
had interviewed we had we went
throughout what i would consider like an
extensive rabbit hole of doing kind of
some of the
like anecdotal stuff with like folks who
had been trying the
like animal-based or meat-based diets
just to try to get a grasp of kind of
what these
individuals were experiencing that was
maybe different from the general
population and
obviously you had a really compelling
story around that type of a
type of an approach so uh yeah
yeah that's been probably a couple of
years at this point i think it has been
uh could we just start off by you giving
a brief background about who you are and
what you do
sure yeah yeah so i uh i guess most
people probably think of me as like an
ultra marathon runner i
do uh typically races historically from
50 kilometers up to the furthest i've
gone is 120
or i'm sorry 200 kilometers or 125 miles
wow
uh which is it's funny i say that and
most people think oh wow that's a long
ways of running in the ultra running
community they're like oh he's just
getting started there's like six day
events there's like
uh like cross-country runs and all these
like big multi-day projects that you can
do as well so it's uh
it's an interesting sport but most
people probably know who i am through
that
uh i also follow what i would consider a
unique diet
in the sense that most endurance
athletes are kind of skewing their diet
towards
moderate carbohydrate consumption
whereas i found
much more success for me personally
following a more low carbohydrate diet
so some folks who are also kind of in
that
world or have found success using that
as a nutritional approach have kind of
come across
some of my stuff as a way to maybe look
at it from a lens of here's how
this nutritional approach can work for
me just from a health standpoint but
then
i want to also be active with whatever
sport i'm doing
so they kind of tie those things
together and think well zack's a
professional runner he eats a low
carbohydrate diet he must be doing
something right or his performance would
suck
yeah so there's some of that as well and
then uh i host a podcast called the
human performance outliers podcast
as well so those are kind of the
coaching podcasting and
training and racing are kind of the
three big things that i'm up to these
days
cool okay uh i want this podcast to kind
of be focused on
how serious athletes can use
and benefit from a low potentially
benefit from a low carb diet so i want
that to be kind of the overarching theme
but before we start you before we start
on that
you mentioned that you're planning on
doing an insanely long run
yeah so can you get into that a bit like
you mentioned that on joe rogan
so what's that about yeah so it's it's
hard to believe that that was uh
coming up on two years ago that i talked
about that on joe's podcast but with
everything that happened in 2020 it's
like we almost lost a year of our lives
it seems like from us
protocol but yeah you know i would i
call myself a single day ultra marathon
runner to date because all the events
i've done so far have been like fit
within a 24-hour window
and as i kind of mentioned before
there's like this vast array of what you
can actually do within the sport
and once you start looking at that you
get into multi-day things then you get
into categories of these like big
projects where you're trying to get from
one point to the next and
it's basically okay wait wait hold on
so i actually didn't know that you could
do multi-day runs so these are multi-day
runs without stopping
uh so that's a little it depends it can
be
so like the standard i'll give you this
there's kind of like
really fringe ones and then there's kind
of the standard and the standard usually
goes up to about six days
where that's like a fairly well
documented one it's uh it's followed a
little more closely over the history of
the sport
uh most folks don't branch up to six
days but like
when you sleep you do right yeah
whenever you okay okay so
you see uh you see a huge range of like
there's a guy who's kind of known as
like
the best uh time they call them timed
events versus like say like
a distance event of like say 100 miles
or 50 miles or whatever
so they go into these other categories
like 12 hours 24 hours 72 hours
and then six days and and so on and so
forth
so like this guy giannis kiros he's got
like a ton of the records with these
timed events
and there's stories of him doing six day
events where he'll have run
like the entire time other than maybe
like eight hours and uh
he's getting a little older now he's i
think he's in the 60s at this point but
there was a race a few years ago that he
was doing in the sixth day
in i think it was like day five and
there's like some live stream of it and
they're like and janice is
just kind of weaving in and out of the
track and running into fences
and stuff oh my god presumably from
sleep deprivation i would imagine with
eight hours of sleep over a six day
period of time
why would anybody do that yeah i don't
think anyone
that i'm aware of wakes up and says i'm
gonna do a six-day event unless they
have some sort of like
life-altering epiphany of some sorts but
what a lot of times happens in the sport
is there's kind of like two main
directions that i see is
people will get into it and they'll find
a specific event or a specific distance
or specific time they really like
and they'll just try to fine-tune that
they'll just like i want to see how far
i can run
in 24 hours and i'm going to spend years
and years just
you know making mistakes learning from
them talking to other people fine-tuning
it and just see if they can eke every
last bit out of that specific event
and then you get these folks who they
get in they dip their toe in with maybe
like a 50 kilometer race which is
considered like the entry to ultra
marathons
and then they'll say oh 50k that was fun
maybe i'll try
you know 80k or 100k and then 100 mile
and then 24 hours and then they start
they just
they crave that kind of like
unfamiliarity of uh
going up in distance so although when
they started they maybe never imagined
themselves
uh doing a six-day event they kind of
find themselves there at some point once
they've exhausted the things that are
shorter than that
this episode is brought to you by true
local true local partners with local
farmers and butchers in your area to
source the best meat
and deliver it to your door things like
100
grass-fed and grass-finished beef
pasture-raised
or raised without antibiotics chicken
lamb bison and more
look at this steak seriously
and this one they're not one-off these
are frozen steaks
they're epic i recommend i actually like
their grain-fed beef batter
wild salmon and their lamb is some of
the best lamb i've ever had
to get started just go to tru local.ca
for canadians or
trulocalusa.com for americans to build
your own personalized
box of meat shows up at your door vacuum
sealed
like so and individually portioned
by an air fryer just throw those stakes
in frozen about
nine minutes aside at 400 degrees you're
welcome
use code mp trulocal.ca or
trulocalusa.com codemp for free stakes
enjoy the rest of the episode i just
watched a documentary on a
i think it's called free climbing it was
a free climber
um and he he climbed this insanely high
like cliff with no gear and was just
like
i feel like people who do that and do
these insane long distance running
there's got to be something something's
a little weird there no offense or
anything
no you're totally right and i think uh i
try to so
that's a really interesting comment
actually because i think
i know that is true but it's easy to
normalize it so like in my head
i've totally normalized running a
hundred miles so sometimes when
someone's talking to me that has never
run maybe not even a runner at all
they're just like they're looking at me
kind of like i've got three heads coming
out of my neck because i'm talking about
running 100 miles as if it's like
the standard or the norm and to
kind of like regain perspective i'll
look at folks like alex honnell doing
like the freak soloing type stuff which
is just
so far away from anything that i could
imagine myself doing
or some of these other like extreme
athletes in sports that are on the
opposite end of the spectrum like some
of these power lifters who are like
you know pulling multiples of their body
weight off the ground and things like
that just to kind of get a perspective
of like
okay you can kind of take almost
anything to an extreme
and unless you kind of do it yourself
you're going to think it's really weird
and i think it's really odd so
it gives you like that ability to kind
of think like okay this is what other
people are thinking about when i'm
talking about
the crazy thing i do that i've
normalized in my head one way or the
other
but it does offer up an interesting like
an interesting community because then
you get this group of people
that is fairly unique in the sporting
world i think because it's this like
really kind of semi-rare behavior or
rare experience
of running all day or more and then
like but it doesn't really matter if
you're the best at it or you're the
worst at it or you're somewhere in
between
everyone kind of goes through the same
kind of range of emotions or experiences
over the course of these things so
there's this like kind of camaraderie
within it as well where
you know you're talking to someone
that's also done it and you're talking
about experiences that are really hard
to explain or to really put words to
but you know they get it because they
actually had that feeling or that
emotion that occurred during it
and you can kind of tell when you're
talking to someone who's done it that
that that's the case so it kind of
creates this uh
unique community within the sport as
well
yeah well it's got to be full of high
achievers if you're that focused on one
thing to just get better and better and
better
you could do that in a whole bunch of
different areas of life but
running would be one of them do you get
a like what's it like mentally
running that far or that long it's it is
kind of
the way i like to describe it is if you
think of like a long time frame like
maybe think of like a year
of just like the different experiences
you've had like you know the highs the
lows and everything between it just kind
of like takes that and just condenses it
into like a single day or a single like
a short period of time so you know you
have these moments where you're
really excited really like you know
happy to be out there you're enjoying it
you're like this is great this is
why i'm here and then you have moments
where you're asking yourself why did i
do this
like what am i what was i thinking i'm
never doing another one of these again
that kind of thing so it's a it's a
really interesting thing to reflect back
on
because since it is a relative short
period of time compared to like a year
or a lifetime
you have a little more of a like a
direct memory of exactly like a clear
vision of like those
ranges of emotion since it is a shorter
time frame and i think that's kind of a
fun thing for people to reflect on and
to look at
um and then you kind of you kind of uh
and this maybe gets a little more into
the folks who
i talked about before where they pick a
specific event or distance and try to
fine-tune it
versus just always going up another
distance and uh
that's where it kind of gets to the
point like well how do i minimize
the negative emotions because it kind of
spirals you'll catch your head
kind of going in one direction that's
maybe a little little negative like
let's say you're
you know 35 miles into 100 mile and
you're like ah you know
i'm not really in a very good place
right now my legs hurt uh
you know my food doesn't taste good
anymore i'm thirsty this and that and
then you know one
egg you grab onto one negative thing and
it introduces another negative thing
which kind of spirals that direction
so you just get better at kind of
catching that and almost redirecting
your mind
it almost becomes like you have two
voices in your head at that point where
like you got the
the negative one and the positive one
and they're kind of always battling each
other to a degree
but you can kind of control it if you're
if you're thinking about it enough to
try to like think of uh
you know the positive stuff and spiral
it that way instead so
like one thing i learned that works
really well for me is
uh you know 100 miles is a long ways
there's no way around it but
when you think of it in the in like a
bigger picture of like i spent let's say
four maybe six months
preparing for this particular race then
you can really in your mind
minimize the hundred mile distance down
to kind of like that final piece of the
puzzle or the last one
yeah so that's sneaky and because when
you think about it like if i get a
mindset of like i got five hours left to
run
five hours of running is a lot you know
even for me or for ultra runners it's a
long time to be out there and it's a
long time to be miserable so
if you think of it like five hours and
you build up that five hours is this
gigantic thing
uh you don't want to go that way so then
you just think of it as like well i
spent
you know you i think most ultra runners
probably spend somewhere in the
neighborhood of 10 plus hours a week
preparing and if you
start adding that up on top of what it's
going to take them to finish a race it
is like okay i can i can do this i'm or
the other way to think about it is
i'm 99 of the way here even at the
starting line of 100 miler do i really
want to bail out on all
99 of that progress uh because i don't
feel great right now in this moment
yeah but so you do a good job of
reframing it
yeah and the other thing too that is
interesting i think is
like that people can't always wrap their
head around in the moment even if
they've had the experience
is you kind of hit these like lows and
when you hit these lows your mind kind
of goes like that's got to be like
kind of a linear process it can always
get worse and it's certainly not going
to get better by continuing the activity
that got me there
so but it does so it's weird like you
could be like have a really bad low at
mile 70
and just kind of you at that point
you're supposed to just kind of minimize
what you're thinking about just thinking
about like small progress
like i'm gonna go like to that next tree
or i'm gonna
you know just just move forward for a
minute and try to like just
inch your way out of it and then you
kind of break through and you can
like i find myself doing this and other
people talk about it too where like five
miles later you hit like a high during
the race itself
and uh you look back you're just
laughing at like how did i just continue
the activity that made me feel that
terrible
five miles ago and now i feel better
than i have all day
after continuing that process that's so
cool
that's very interesting okay so you
mentioned how how does eating
and drinking work for these really long
runs
yeah and i think that's that's where
like that variable
is kind of first pops up in like the
marathon distance where
most folks find that they're going to
want to eat and they're going to
probably drink
something during a marathon and the
marathon is interesting because it's
just long enough where in most cases
people are going to benefit from that
uh when you start getting up to like a
hundred miles now you're talking you
know from most folks probably between
especially if it's a trail race 20 to 30
hours of time so
you know you're going through multiple
different meal time frames and things
like that
as well as the you know thousands of
extra calories you're burning being out
there moving the entire time
so people recognize i think right away
like eating and drinking is a necessity
and then the next piece of puzzle is
like well how do i do that so
for drinking uh the the recommendations
for like single day ultras
is to have like around 500 or 700
milligrams of electrolytes per liter of
fluid you drink
so usually i like to start with that
because
digestion can get screwed up if you're
like severely dehydrated or even
mildly dehydrated what do you use for
electrolytes
um so a kind of a combination of things
there's basically
three ways to get them in three kind of
like standard ways one is just through
what you're eating
so like a lot of the sports products and
a lot of the foods have some
electrolytes in them
so i usually start with that and say
like okay how much electrolytes am i
just gonna get in from the
fueling process and then like you
supplement it
otherwise so like there's powdered
versions and there's like little
capsules
so if i'm gonna kind of put it inside a
bottle i'll
i'll use like element which makes uh
like a little packets that are super
easy to you can put like
i could easily stick like five or six of
those in a pocket and i wouldn't even
know they were there
so they're real easy to kind of use like
in the middle of a race especially if
you're
in a in a race where you're kind of
taking care of yourself versus having a
crew hand you everything you need
uh and those ones have like a thousand
milligrams of electrolytes in one little
packet so you can take care of like
almost two liters worth of water with
one of those
uh and then the other ways those little
little capsules which can be nice if you
kind of have like
what you call like a like a sour stomach
or like you're just
food isn't tasting good you know the
element stuff and most these powdered
electrolytes do have a little bit of a
sweeter flavor to it so
you know you find yourself 15 hours into
a race and
you know whatever sweet things you had
been eating or drinking or starting to
get a little unappetizing or
yeah what's called palette fatigue then
sometimes it's easier
i'm saying yeah as if i understand but
like i don't
anyway continue yeah so like that's kind
of another way to get it if you want to
have like a flavorless version of it too
or if uh
you know some people find it easier just
to kind of have those in a little
ziplock bag because those are basically
weightless as well you're not going to
notice they're there
um so yeah and then and then you kind of
just like
build your your fluid and hydration
stuff around
kind of those numbers and some folks are
going to recognize that they need a
little more some are going to maybe need
a little less and you can kind of
tease that out in training and races as
to where that is
um but then it comes to like the fueling
side of it
so the way i like to describe the
fueling for ultra marathons
is it is really low intensity when
you're running that low
long like even the fastest guys and gals
in the sport have to come way below
their normal
like what they would run for like a 5k
or a 10k in order to
what speed is that on average it just
depends
like so if you do like so i do a lot
more flat runnable
stuff so for me like my fastest hundred
mile
pace is 6 47 and a half minutes per mile
for
for 100 miles and you know that's uh
it was a world record in 2019 actually
just recently got broke so the guy who
broke it averaged 645
per uh per mile for 100 miles so it's uh
that's that's when i think people can
usually wrap their heads around a little
bit more because it's like a consistent
environment
if they've done running in the past they
kind of have a grasp of like controlled
surfaces
like road marathon courses and things
like that um
when you get up into like the mountains
and things like that there's this
there's the the massive environmental
barrier or
or hurdle or variable to get over where
um for example one of the most
popular competitive 100 milers in the
united states is the western states 100
which is happening next weekend
or not next week about the weekend after
and uh
that one it has like basically
three very unique sections of it one you
go up into the high country
in in the sierras where you're at like i
think it peaks out at
9 200 feet and then you kind of come
down the high country and you go into a
series of canyons there's like four main
canyons we're just going up and down it
can be anything from like
upwards like 20 plus percent incline or
decline through there
and then you hit this stretch where you
just kind of gradually go downhill for a
good chunk of the final part of the race
and
you know pace is very greatly in there
especially when you're going uphill
versus downhill
um some of the best in the sport have
been able to average
around like an eight minute mile pace on
on that course which is
pretty impressive when you think of it
as it's got 17 000 feet of climbing and
23 000 feet of descent in that on that
course so
like you know just moving and then the
canyons can get into 100 plus degrees so
there's another variable that impacts
performance
you have you have the weather component
which as you can kind of see that's like
it becomes this this
kind of uh i was i was talking with lex
friedman about this where like
sometimes you jump into the sport and i
think there is some value of like
not knowing how many variables there are
because it can overwhelm you and then
scary yeah and then you just you're just
you're so much anxiety goes into
thinking about that that you just burned
yourself out mentally before you even
started the race
but so it's like the first coat go over
sometimes you're kind of playing
checkers
with it where you're like okay there's
like a couple main variables i need to
account for like i probably should train
i should probably figure out how to eat
and drink
and then once you do those you figure
out like oh now i need to figure out how
to like topically cool
and i need to figure out how to manage
like this environment or this situation
like what do i do if i get a blister on
my foot and things like that
so so then you go from kind of playing
checkers to like okay now i'm playing
chess now i'm thinking about some of
these smaller variables because i
figured out some of the big movers like
how to get enough fluid in how to get
enough food in
you know how to keep moving when i don't
want to and some of the ones that people
that
pop into your head like a little more
readily when you think about running all
day long
okay okay but yeah the food part too is
uh so i think i went on a tangent there
for a bit but
the the eating part of it is interesting
because the way i look at it is
ultimately you kind of have two fuel
tanks that you're gonna use on race day
and
one is your body fat uh so like that's
the big fuel tank right like even the
leanest endurance athletes on the planet
have a much bigger
body fat store than they do their second
fuel tank which is their like liver and
muscle glycogen
so you know the average endurance
athlete is probably carrying around
somewhere in the neighborhood about 2
000
calories with their uh muscle glycogen
and liver glycogen
so you can easily deplete that over the
course of a day
whereas you're not going to necessarily
you're not going to deplete your body
fat stores
so when it comes to race day you want to
kind of defend
your liver muscle glycogen uh and
there's different ways to do that you'll
have folks that are kind of like
moderate high carbohydrate
where they're going to defend that by
trying to eat as much carbohydrate as
they can
you see some incredibly strong digestive
tracts on that side of the
the sport but with that said that's uh
you know the position paper which
recommends like 50 to 70 grams of
carbohydrate per hour
you know also reports like a 60
digestive issue that occurs at some
point during these single day events so
for a lot of people it can be a bit of a
coin flip as to like whether they can
actually get that sort of stuff down
um to me the way i look at it is i think
it's just you know i've worked with
over like thousands of people at this
point within ultra running and stuff and
i mean there's folks who can do it
there's folks who are eating four or
five hundred calories an hour of
almost pure carbohydrate and it doesn't
seem to bother them they're like no
worse for the wear they just mainline
this stuff
and there's folks who uh you know they
start getting anywhere near like even
like 100 to 200 calories an hour and
they start like losing their
their digestion just starts failing on
them they just don't feel great and they
it's that sounds horrible yeah well the
way i describe it too
is like you think about it like if you
think let's just think of a day
and if you think of like four to five
hundred calories of
basically candy because that's
essentially what a lot of the sports
product is is like
refined carbohydrate it lay that out on
like your coffee table on your couch
for like 12 hours worth of that and look
at that and think like if i ate that
just sitting on a couch how miserable
you'd feel
like now imagine doing that while you're
running 100 miles and
or whatever distance it is you're going
and i think it is a little more
clear to people as to why that doesn't
necessarily work for everybody
uh so like some folks they decide like
myself included
i want to defend my liver and muscle
glycogen
by minimizing the amount of
carbohydrates my body is required to use
at the intensity that i'm going to raise
so the other way to do that is to
increase your fat oxidation rates
uh you know yeah so like the way to
think about it like let's say you had
two of me
and we determined that at seven minute
mile pace
a certain diet would produce like a 50
50 split where my body would burn like
half carbohydrates half fats
and then through a different
intervention i can get that to be
like say 85 fat 15 carbohydrate
you take those two versions of myself
the 85 15 and the 50 50
the 50 50 person is going to have to
defend muscle glycogen more aggressively
through exogenous carbohydrate during
the event itself
versus the 85 15 i that that version of
me can get away with a lot less
and if i'm someone who has digestive
issues for me personally usually if i
start going above maybe like 40 grams of
carbohydrate per hour
i'll start to notice digestive issues
are more likely to happen especially as
i kind of get beyond like the six to
eight hour time frame
uh so i know for 100 miles which is
going to take me even on a flat
controllable surface
you know upwards 12 hours that uh
i'm tempting fate if i'm trying to put
in that standard recommendation of 50 to
70 grams of carbohydrate per hour
uh so i want to make sure i'm defending
my muscle glycogen at least enough or i
guess the other way to look at is get
fat adapted enough to defend
the majority of my nutrition from coming
off of
essentially body fat which i can easily
replace after the event if i if i want
to or need to
okay interesting so do you do you gain
weight
in in fat before these long distance
runs
not necessarily before although like i
think there's some
application for that for some of these
longer like stage or
type of things where you're going multi
days or weeks
that it could be beneficial to kind of
essentially build yourself an onboard
fuel station
um but for these single day ones like
even if i would get like as lean as i've
ever gotten before
there's still enough body fat on board
for me to get through
a single day event like i'm not going to
deplete that um
so then you're kind of and then the
shorter events who you are dealing with
like power weight ratio and stuff like
that so
like if you can get away with not
carrying around say an extra pound of
of weight and it's not going to
negatively impact your performance by
not having that there then i usually say
we'll defer that to after the race
because after the race i'm not going to
do hardly anything for a few days if not
a week plus
so then it's like i can just start
eating like really fatty foods and gain
back whatever i lost from the fat
standpoint on race day pretty quickly
within a couple days if i
if i need to okay that makes way more
sense to me
so how often do you have to eat on a run
and what do you eat on a run if you're
doing low carb
yeah so that's where it gets kind of
interesting cause i think a lot of times
people think
um well if i'm low carb if i'm ketogenic
i should be eating fats and proteins
versus the standard kind of
carbohydrate-based
nutrition uh and there is some
application to that
i think like if it's like say someone i
i'll work with folks sometimes they're
like i'm
strict keto or i'm zero carb and you
know for whatever reason you know maybe
it's someone who's
like you i mean you had a great episode
with some of the folks who have went
zero carb carnivore because they had all
series of things that got cleared up
from it
you know if you're someone like that
like you're not telling that person to
bring back
even 10 grams of carbohydrate per hour
because they're like no i remember where
i went when i started deviating from
this nutritional approach that has
cleared up so many other
health elements in my life so like that
person
would probably benefit i think from
eating something still on these longer
sessions
just because i think there is probably a
motivation factor of saying like oh at
this point i'm gonna
i'm gonna be able to have this make
sense and it does seem weird
from the outside like that that that
would be a motivator but you'd be
the other interesting thing about altras
is like you can really find
really goofy things that will motivate
you in the moment like even like
oh in two miles i get this water bottle
and
and then you think like you just fixate
on that water bottle and that distracts
you from like the 30 miles that are
coming after that
so building that sort of stuff into a
plan can be useful
um obviously you know not everyone wants
to put themselves in a huge
energy deficit especially in training so
if you're like a keto
low carb zero carb endurance athlete or
ultra marathoner
you might decide i'm doing this five to
six hour run on saturday morning
i don't want to put myself in a position
where after the run i have to eat
you know four or five thousand calories
in a single meal to make up for that
calorie deficit so i can go out and do
another workout the next day
uh because in ultra running up one thing
that's fairly common in these plans is
what they call like blocking your long
run
where you instead of trying to go like a
really long well it's still a really
long distance but
going like anywhere near your race
distance in one single long run you do
like one on saturday morning and another
one on sunday morning
and just you kind of compound it into a
tighter window
and if you're doing that like let's say
you do five six hours saturday and then
five six hours sunday
you probably want to stay on top of your
energy demands to a degree
on saturday so that on sunday you don't
wake up feeling incredibly flat
uh yeah so for that for that athlete you
know you're going to want to have some
sort of fat sources in during that run
most likely
there's not a lot of like just kind of
sports
products that offer up that the one i
i'm partnered with a brand that actually
does called
s fuels and they make a powder that
actually is fat and protein based
okay so it kind of goes along the lines
of like what you think with like
you know folks in like the keto
community you can focus on like mct
oils and things like that exogenous
ketones
that sort of stuff yep yeah so and then
some people will turn to whole food
options too where you know they'll bring
out uh you know like some nut butters or
something like that or
things that that they have that are more
solid food which is
a good idea i think like most people
find it
struggle find have a hard time if
they're doing like one specific type of
fuel
for an entire race like all sports
products or all whole food options
usually there's like a nice like kind of
blend between the two that
pans out a little bit better for uh for
people in terms of
you know getting through the race itself
or that so
those folks are going to be using stuff
like that um the
the moderate high carb groups they're
just going to be practicing kind of what
they would be doing on race day more or
less where they're
introducing whatever sports product
whatever carbohydrate-based solid foods
they're going to eat on on race day
um other times i'll do like what i call
like a
fat adaptation field test where i'm not
necessarily thinking about
like here's an example like if i had a
five hour run
the next day's a rest day so i'm not
worried about
like trying to perform again the next
day i'm more concerned about like
how do i feel just like in terms of like
fat metabolism
like can i do a four to five hour run
with just water and electrolytes and
feel very
energy consistent throughout versus
getting to three or four hours and
feeling like i'm
falling apart or like you know having a
more like erratic emotions and things
like that
uh you know that's a good indication for
me and it's a little easier for like
folks i'm working with to do versus
going into like a you know a laboratory
and getting a metabolic test
uh to just kind of see like well how
does it actually work in the field for
me
so i'll do these like fat adaptation
field tests where i'll just do water and
electrolytes for
for a long run interesting you'll get a
pretty big
calorie deficit after that but you know
then if you have a rest day the next day
no problem it's actually a little more
convenient because then you don't
you can eat a ton on your rest day and
catch up then
okay okay interesting so uh one of the
questions i assume people would have
especially if they're athletes
that are potentially interested in going
low carb is
how do you function without that much
you know
carb or that much glucose how do your
muscles and your brain function like
this
yeah so it's you know you're basically
kind of like what i said before like
you're just you're skewing your ratios
kind of across the intensity spectrum to
just
prioritizing burning higher rates of fat
um
the there is a trade-off there's a
trade-off with everything though like
the way i look at it is like you maybe
you look at the trade-off
by becoming a moderate high carbohydrate
athlete is that you're going to be
more heavily reliant on that fuel source
which means
since it's your smaller fuel tank you're
going to have to stay on top of that
you're going to be having to eat
frequent meals
you're going to have to be eating
frequently during your workouts you
might have a wider range of them
like like potential outcomes from
digestion on race day
you may be like one of the things that
skewed me towards low carb was
when i was moderate high carb you know
i'd have good workouts but the rest of
the day i felt like i was kind of on a
roller coaster ride where i'd feel like
i had a ton energy or i felt like i
could just literally lay down anywhere
and take a nap
um so like the
when you're when you're when you switch
that to kind of prioritizing fat
you have a more consistent energy source
so you're going to maybe feel a little
more like
like even keel throughout the day
there's not going to be as many like
just like
hyperactive episodes and like depressive
episodes
uh but at the the trade-off there is
it's more steps so it's a little harder
from just like as like a it's a little
more time
sensitive in the sense that your body
has to go through more steps to break
down fat and use that as an energy
source
than it does to just pull glycogen out
of your muscle
so that becomes an issue sometimes
especially if you're like let's say
you're an olympic marathoner
the reason we don't see olympic
marathoners following like a ketogenic
diet
is because their intensity if we take
like the elite men we're running low two
hours
it's this perfect balance of just long
enough where they can
really dip into their muscle and liver
glycogen but it's just fast enough that
they're gonna be skewing those ratios
towards
uh you know glycogen stores more
aggressively because it's just a quick
enough pace that their body needs to
eliminate some of those
extra steps it takes to break down fat
uh
so for them it's kind of like sometimes
i wonder if it's like the selection
process identifies that to a degree
where like in order
to even get through the the like years
and years of what it takes to become an
olympic marathon or just going to
identify people who do really well with
carbohydrates because
uh that's kind of what is being used in
the energy system
like primarily on race day versus like
maybe someone like myself or someone who
just can't tolerate that much
carbohydrate for whatever reason
you know they're going to get weeded out
pretty quick at the at the pointy end of
the spear when we're talking
you know olympic level athletes but then
then we're talking about an incredibly
tiny population
so most people don't have the lifestyle
of
like an olympic athlete like these
olympic athletes wake up every morning
thinking everything i do today is gonna
be revolved around preparing for this
event that i'm gonna do in four years
the average person wakes up i've got my
job i've got my family i've got like
these other interests and then i've got
this uh you know this training plan i'm
trying to
wedge into all of it and sometimes
those variables that come with the
average person life
if they clean if those are getting
improved from having that more steady
energy
support from kind of burning higher
rates of fat it cleans up so many other
variables in their life it allows their
performance to improve because
it doesn't get messy and elsewhere so
it's a lot of times it's just kind of
balancing out the negatives of one
approach with the positives of one
approach
and finding out where those variables
fall with your specific
situation and then kind of going from
there so
for the for some folks and i see this
all the time i'll be working with
someone who's you know they're not maybe
winning the marathon race but they're
running much faster than they ever have
before they're continually improving
and some of that might be because they
went on a low carbohydrate diet and for
whatever reason that was more
sustainable for them from just an energy
intake standpoint and they you know lost
10 pounds of extra weight now their
power weight ratio is improved
and since they can stick to that diet
versus a more standard approach which
they had a harder time
being you know sticking to or having
work for them
you know the the pros outweighed the
cons in that scenario so for them i'm
not going to say
well if we brought you up to moderate
high carbohydrate you'd run
three minutes faster yet when that may
not even be their number one priority in
life
or it might not even actually yield that
benefit for them at the individual level
uh it gets more interesting though in my
opinion when you get up in distance
because once you start getting up to
events that take 20
30 hours now we're in a realm of
intensity that is
low enough where on paper we don't have
great
research on just nutrition needs for
these long events just because it's like
almost impossible to do and then control
for all the variables and everything
that could be at play and
and to be honest i mean we know about
variables within ultra marathoning but
there's
probably tons more that we don't even
know of that are happening
just independently while we're out there
kind of uh
experimenting with ourselves more or
less and uh
you know for some folks like if you can
with that lower
energy or that lower intensity you just
don't you you have time to take those
extra steps to burn fat
so uh you know let's say like
i see okay if you're running like say
like
two-thirds of the pace that you're
capable of running for like
an all-out five-kilometer race over the
course of
12 hours or whatever distance you're
doing
now like it's slow enough where your
body can break down that fatty acid
convert it into an energy source and
deliver it to your muscles versus just
pulling that energy straight out of your
muscle which is going to be less steps
in a little
little faster so that's where i think it
gets really fun and interesting because
you know i i mean i see people on both
ends of the spectrum have success
so it's uh i think there's i like that
though i think it's uh
when when i was a teacher i'd always
loved this aspect too where you kind of
have
well here's what we recommend in our our
curriculum or our education process
and that's probably going to work great
for like maybe 60 to 70 percent
like that middle of the bell curve but
then we have like these polar ends where
you get like
kind of gifted talented students and
then you also have like students with
like some extra needs where they just
they don't learn in a traditional way
but if you can find a way for them
to get excited and learn given their
unique set of circumstances
you know they can flourish too but
they're just not going to fit nice and
cleanly within that kind of standard
recommendation
and i see a lot of that i think in the
nutrition world and i see a lot of that
with ultramarathoning as well and i
think it's kind of an exciting component
of it
are you putting the special needs kids
as the high carb athletes or the zero
carb athletes
i put i put the the moderate high carb
folks as just like the standard and i
think that's probably the
k like that middle of the bell curve and
i think that's just as much a product of
our food environment
i mean the way i describe it is if if we
went into the grocery store
and blindfolded ourselves and just
started randomly grabbing stuff off the
shelf
you're gonna find yourself probably at a
moderate carbohydrate diet unless you
somehow like
stumble into like the meat department or
something like that
but yeah so like most people i don't
think are
first of all they're getting raised in
an environment that is
gonna promote moderate to high
carbohydrate as kind of a foundational
element
so they're hearing that and then the so
the foods they're going to be getting
from their parents are going to probably
be moderate to high carbohydrate
and they're probably not going to change
that unless they're compelled to
you know it's why i like to pay
attention to why would you
they're tasty well and it's yeah they're
tasty you have a lot more options it's
like
uh i mean i i say that but then uh maria
emmerich has like some of the
most interesting social media posts
around just like uh low carbohydrate
options that
fit within the realm of the diet but
yeah basically mimic the alternative
uh but i think it's interesting then
because then it's like
yeah what it's one it's kind of that i'm
not gonna change something that's not
broken
um and i think there's probably a lot of
people who've also normalized it too
where they don't really know they're
operating maybe sub-optimally
but yes i think that's a lot of it
i think a lot of it i talk to a lot of
people who are in the fitness industry
um that say oh no this works really well
for me i'm like well have you tried
anything different
ever it's like no i'm worried about my
performance
it's like well maybe you should worry
about your performance now like what if
you're operating at 70
you've never operated at 90 and you
don't even know what it's like
you're not even testing it out that's
what happened to me when i went on
zero carb i was like operating at my
entire life at like 40
and i went to 80 and was like what this
reality exists
why did you end up going low-carb yeah
yeah
the you know i went kind of my approach
was maybe it was not nearly as
like life-altering as i think yours and
some of the other folks
it was more you know i was it was in
2011 near the end of the year i had just
kind of completed what i would consider
my first like full season of ultra
marathon running i had done like 350
milers that that fall
early winter and i was like in love with
the sport it was like my
real big introduction to it uh my
workouts and my races were going well
enough
but uh i was i was a teacher at the time
so
like i'd wake up in the morning i would
do a workout then i'd go to work and
then sometimes i'd do a workout after
and then kind of rinse and repeat it was
a very kind of monkish lifestyle for a
bit
uh but you know what i noticed during
that
was i'd have the energy to do well in
the workout in the morning
but then like i would have like these
big rollercoaster energy levels during
the day
and the thing that really kind of stuck
out to me is like at the end of the day
when i would go to bed i got to a point
where i
kind of inched my way to a point where i
was like blocking off like 10 hours
a night just to try to get like eight
eight and a half hours of sleep
and because i'd wake up like three or
four times it would take me like you
know 10 minutes here 20 minutes there to
fall back asleep and
eventually got to a point where i was
like this is ridiculous because
historically
i was a great sleeper like all the way
through college
i would be i'd go to bed when i go to
bed and i'd wake up eight maybe nine
hours
later if i had like done a really big
workout or something like that and
it was just such an afterthought because
it was just so seamless
that that didn't make sense to me it was
like a sign or a flag a red flag in my
head that like
whatever i'm doing is not sustainable
long term
because you know sleep is something that
oftentimes gets overlooked i think from
the performance
side of stuff where everyone thinks
about the workout like did you nail the
workout and then if you nailed the
workout great let's move on to the next
they want to kind of hyper focus on
these like isolated things
but if you look at the entirety of a
training program or a career it's like
sleep is like that part where the
workout's actually benefiting you
like you tear yourself down in the
workout you build yourself back up when
you're sleeping and you're recovering
so i knew it wasn't a sustainable
direction to had to just be sleeping
poorly and i i kind of lucked out where
at the same time i was also i had this
like conversation in my head of uh
like i mean i was young i was like who
was i at that time i think i was like
20 probably 25 25
and i was so i was like just kind of
starting my adult life more or less
and i was thinking what what am i doing
here i'm like waking up in the morning
and i'm running
i'm going to work i'm running again and
then i'm going to bed
and then like if i'm not in a peak
training phase
on the weekend i can go do stuff with
some friends but otherwise it's like
like i'm trying to think like well is
this going to be fulfilling in 10 years
and 15 years and 20 years if i kind of
keep doing this
so i started to try to find ways to add
a little flavor to that experience and
one of them one of the ways i did that
was i started
you know rather than going out for like
a two hour run in the morning before
work i'd go out for a two hour run by
listen to a podcast and try to learn
something and
i went down like some nutrition topics
and came across kind of low carbohydrate
stuff and then i was really fortunate i
got connected quite quickly after that
with uh
dr jeff volk and dr steven finney who
are
kind of two of the big kind of guys in
the ketogenic performance world
and they kind of laid out a lot of just
like here are some of the things to look
out for if you're going to try this
approach to try to minimize the amount
of trial and erroring you're going to
have to do
to get it right can we talk about that a
bit
after just to give some hints to other
people okay yeah absolutely and i think
for me the interesting thing was
i i say i lucked out because there's
like a series of things that i think
just happened
somewhat i wouldn't say accidentally but
they happened at the right timeline
so i had just finished my racing season
so i didn't have structure training in
place
which i think is the best time if you're
going to try to like
do any type of dietary alteration is
doing it in the offseason
because like if you're yeah you're
throwing a huge wrench into things if
you're trying to like
tease that out with all these other
variables that come into like
performance and training
so i had about a month where i was still
running but
whatever i ran was just kind of whatever
i felt like running if i didn't feel
like it for the day
i'd take off if i did i would and it was
just all enjoyment only enjoyment
you know nothing more than that so i
went pretty strict low carb like the
standard like 50 grams of carbohydrates
or last for about
about a month and through so was that
ketogenic
yeah yeah i tried to do what uh
you know what the what the dr volk and
dr finney recommended was
like rather than kind of if i had the
opportunity to kind of do
like do it in the off season was just do
it strict see how that feels just so you
have an idea of it and then
you know once you get back into training
obviously you know fuel your body with
what you need to get the workouts in and
prioritize performance if you want to
but that's kind of step two so first was
just seeing like
is this something that i can that i
would enjoy enough to make it
sustainable is it something that's
actually gonna make things better versus
worse you know
i didn't really have any idea how i was
gonna respond to it
uh but what i did notice was uh almost
immediately within the first week i
started sleeping through the night again
like i couldn't testing it was really
shocking actually because it was
like i remember i woke up one morning
and i was almost like confused
because i was like is it really time to
get up like usually i would have woken
up three or four times between the time
i went to bed in the time i woke up
and when that kind of continued for the
remainder of that
that kind of first trial phase i was
like okay well that's that's definitely
a positive for me anyway
um just for clarity i mean i've worked
with folks and talked to folks who
have had the exact opposite experience
where i've actually
i've actually had so one of the problems
i've had and i still don't exactly know
what to do about it i think it's
stressed to tell you the truth i think
it's stressed in the last few years
my parents being sick because i don't
think i had it before that when i went
zero carb but i definitely don't sleep
as well since i had a baby and then
since i've been stressed and i when i
had carbs before like i
passed out i could sleep for like 12
hours easy
like a rock and now i'm like any noise
or anything wakes me up
yeah i wonder because like stress also
can like
promote like your body to release some
of the like the liver glycogen i think
so like i wonder if like
if that triggers that you end up having
a chronically low liver glycogen or
something and that makes it harder to
sleep
i'm not sure exactly but like i mean
because there's clearly like polar ends
of the like experiences with that but
for whatever reason
the low carb was beneficial for that for
me
um so i i latched on to that and the
other thing i noticed really quickly
within the first couple weeks was you
know it was this would have been fall of
2011 so i was like full on in the first
semester of teaching
i was like this is amazing i'd like go
to school and
from eight o'clock to 3 30 or whatever
the time frame was
i just had like a steady line of energy
like i never felt like i was like
like hyperactive i never felt like i
needed to take a nap
and that was just so much more of an
enjoyable experience it was a lot easier
you know i was
teaching seventh grade at the time so
it's like you want to have
very steady energy levels when you're
teaching seventh grade you don't want to
be like
too too uh hyper or too like like
low energy either because those kids
aren't gonna they're not gonna care
yeah and so that was another thing where
i was like okay these are two really big
benefits for me um the one thing that
took a little bit longer
was just like how does that impact
training
so i wasn't structured training but i
was running
so what that means is like you know i'd
wake up in the morning and if i felt
good maybe i'd go out for like a 60
minute easy run i wouldn't do any
workouts or anything like that where it
was like i'm trying to run a fast
interval or
you know run a specific pace and i had
this kind of weird experience where
i'd go out sometimes and i'd feel just
normal
like nothing different then i have these
other times where i felt like the
intensity was the same
as what i would be doing for like say a
seven minute mile pace but then i'd look
down at my watch it'd be like an eight
and a half minute mile pace
so there was like some weird like i
don't know if my body was just adjusting
to the different fuel
substrate usage or something like that
during that time uh
but by the end of maybe the first month
that cleared up so those like really
easy
like the way the easiest way for folks
who are non-runners is think there's
kind of like these different categories
of intensity
there's like an easy intensity which is
just like a pace you could run like
with carrying a great conversation
multi-sentence conversation
probably could do it for hours um
whether that's walking running or
otherwise
and then there's like moderate intensity
which is like you know your breathing
gets a little more labored you can
probably
like speak a sentence or so or some
phrases but much beyond that is going to
get a little more
tedious you start breathing more through
your mouth uh that sort of stuff and
then you get like high intensity stuff
which people think of as like just short
interval repeats and things like that
so at that point i was doing all easy
stuff and that all normalized like i got
to a point where those
weird days where i was running a minute
to two minutes per mile slower at the
same intensity
started like phasing out to where i was
running that same kind of pace i
normally would
at that effort level within the easy
spectrum
easy intensity spectrum so then kind of
the next step was
okay well now i need to get around to
training for a race eventually which for
me means kind of structuring my training
periodizing it meaning i'm going to be
doing different types of workouts during
different different phases of the
training cycle
uh and that those kind of like go back
to those
intensity spectrums too there's like i
always try to build
towards what's most specific on race day
so if i'm doing something long and slow
i'm going to be doing a lot of long slow
slow stuff as i get close to
the race but far from the race i'm going
to work on weaknesses and work on things
that are going to benefit my performance
but are least specific to the pace i'm
going to do
on race day itself so that's kind of
another thing that makes ultra running
unique is it's kind of like the reverse
of a normal endurance event where
if i'm training for like a 5k um i might
be doing short intervals near the end of
that plan because those short intervals
are going to mimic the pace i would do
for that five kilometer
whereas if i'm doing 100 miles i'm going
to be doing long slow runs at the end
because that's going to mimic the pace
i'm going to be doing on race day
doesn't mean short intervals aren't
important they can still be very
valuable i'm just going to do them early
in the plan because they're non-specific
they may be a weakness that kind of
stuff
so then i had to decide like well how
does this transfer to that
because i had two different lifestyles
essentially i had my offseason lifestyle
and my in-season lifestyle
and so i was kind of curious about how
that how that would go and i would say
it probably took
a good year or so before i really found
kind of a
system that worked well for me within
that and all it basically meant for me
was strict ketogenic didn't seem like
the
way to go for me i felt like i could run
low intensity stuff very consistency but
as soon as i'd start dropping in
uh you know multiple short interval
sessions or multiple
modern intensity sessions in a week's
time frame i would find that i couldn't
quite
perform the way i would have been able
to in the past when i was on a moderate
to high carbohydrate diet
so then my question was well there's
there's there's probably some maybe some
middle ground here
uh i didn't necessarily want to just say
okay well it's back to moderate carb for
me because i
want to prioritize performance i just
kind of inched it up
so like rather than going back up to
like maybe 60 70 carbohydrate like i
would have in the past is
i just started introducing a little more
carbohydrate around
some of those sessions that are going to
be a little more intense
so what that meant for me is rather than
being kind of strict keto which was
usually around
maybe five percent of my intake coming
from carbohydrate
i was kind of moving that up closer to
you know anywhere from
from that five percent during like off
season
like easy recovery days upwards to like
20 sometimes
it's pretty rare but every once while
i'll go up to maybe 30 of my intake
coming from carbohydrate
and a lot of time that's all going to be
kind of congested around
the workouts that are going to maybe
require a little more of a glycolytic
effect or uh
you know interesting a quick energy
source so
what do you use as a as a carb when you
do higher carb like that
there's not that that's high carb right
yeah it is funny because like it's
it's in the that's why i i think
sometimes people struggle to grasp what
i'm doing
because they'll like they'll look at my
off season um
they'll be like oh well that's strict
keto so zach is a strict ketogenic
athlete and then
someone will look at well what what is
eating on race day
and then on race day i'm kind of doing
we talked about before i'm leaning on
body fat for my fat metabolism so i'm
probably still burning 80 90
fat but i'm defending muscle glycogen
with
small amounts of carbohydrates so they
look at what i actually ingest and
they're like oh that's mostly
carbohydrate
so you use a carbohydrate-based athlete
and then there's everything in between
during the training too
but when you look at it kind of big
picture over the course of like an
entire training block
i'm probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of like say maybe on
average 10 to 15 percent of my intake
coming from carbohydrate
and then you know upwards to 20 from
protein and then
whatever the balance is between uh the
carbs i take in and the fats are going
to make up the fat percentage so that's
usually in like the 60 to 70
range uh and then in terms of what
carbohydrates it usually just depends
on whether it is carbohydrates i'm
eating in my
daily nutrition versus what i'm eating
if i'm doing it out on like a workout or
a long run or something
like that because i talked about kind of
like those fat adaptation field tests
uh there's a second component to that
where once i know
okay i'm fat adapted enough i don't
necessarily need to like push that
needle anymore
because it kind of operates on a
spectrum i think a lot of times people
get in this mindset of like i either
need to be
all fat adapted or all carb dependent
and in reality there's like a spectrum
there
so the question is usually well what is
your lifestyle
where does that lifestyle put you on
that spectrum in terms of how you're
going to perform
and what's going to work for you so once
i get
quote unquote fat adapted enough now i'm
not concerned about doing these like
four or five hour runs with no fuel
now i'm more concerned about practicing
what i'm going to do on race day from a
feeling standpoint so i can predict how
my body's going to respond to it
so for those intro workout things i'll
do a blend between
like solid foods and sport lip products
so i'll use s fuels raised plus which
has like maybe 14
15 grams of carbohydrate in it as like a
powder i'll put in a bottle
um it also has some electrolytes in it
so i can kind of check two things off
with
one with that and then for the solid
food option i usually try to go to the
opposite side of the spectrum from uh
just a consistency and a flavor
standpoint uh so i'll get something
that's maybe saltier a little more
savory like
like a cracker or like maybe some
sourdough bread or something like that
i've been some solid food options that's
worked well for me in the past
and i'll start kind of introducing those
into some of those longer runs and
and workouts just to remind myself of
what it's going to be like to kind of do
that on race day
and then it's like there's the nutrition
that i'll be doing during
my normal meals so what i'll do is you
know most my meals even when i'm
bringing back some carbohydrates are
still going to be the majority fat and
protein
but there's a small carb component there
and for this what i found working with
other people is
i to make it more sustainable i think
like
i usually tell them let's let's
reasonably pick like three or four
carbohydrate sources that
that maybe you miss or that you feel are
going to help you stick to this approach
and then layer those in so you don't you
don't feel like okay i've got to like
completely cut this out of my life
forever and there's individual
components with that as well obviously
we couldn't just say like
michaela pick your favorite
carbohydrates let's introduce that
because if that kind of like
puts you in an angel food cake right
yeah
yeah just a little bit yeah yeah yeah
so so that's why i say within reason and
at the individual level as
you know some people respond differently
to certain stuff so it's like it's like
yeah i want that snickers bar or that
angel food cake but we know what happens
when i introduce that so we need to stay
away from that
so for me you know i'll do a lot of just
like
kind of like a potato starch based stuff
for the carbohydrate sources
um you know variety different types
whether it's just like kind of a plain
potato like a
sweet potato and all the different kind
of iterations of that
melons and berries i found a lot of
success with like honey
something i'll work work well with i
don't do this one as often but
my wife is a big sourdough bread fan so
it's just around more often now so i've
played around with that and
and and that's actually been an
interesting one for me too because it's
a little
easier to use as a race fuel too than
say like
i'm not i'm less likely to say like i'll
give me an apple in the middle of a race
sweet potato yeah yeah or sweet potato
and although i mean that's not super
uncommon at these aid stations sometimes
you can get like salted potatoes which
is a little bit can be good
uh but but it's a little harder to plan
for i'm not gonna go out there on a long
run with uh like a pack on it
like a baked potato sitting in the back
of it either so but you know half a
slice of sourdough bread is pretty easy
to pack and
and bring along you can put some like
peanut butter almond butter on it too
and add a few more calories if you need
to
and and that's kind of what i'll be
doing then uh
i don't necessarily make it like
absolute those aren't like the only
things i do
i you know i'll deviate and i'll have
things i normally wouldn't from time to
time just to kind of keep things
uh less regimental or less strict
especially if it's like not
i'm not in like a real like peaking
phase of training and things like that
but i usually try to be uh good about
keeping the ratios of fast carbs and
proteins where i found work well for me
um within that spectrum of training and
uh
that's what probably took me about a
year and a half to maybe two years to
really fine tune was
okay i figured out what worked well for
me when i'm doing short intervals
and we got that checked off the list
found out what works well for me when i
kind of transition from short intervals
to maybe longer intervals or what you'd
call like a tempo run
and that's kind of an intensity that you
could do all out if you're just to run
as
far as you could in 60 minutes uh so if
on the intensity spectrum that's maybe
where that one would fall and then i
find like well this is what works well
for me
when i'm kind of in that peaking phase
where i'm moving away from
a lot of the intensity and saving that
time and energy to build up my long run
my race specific uh type activities and
like well you know what fuels what
fueling or what ratios work well in
there
um so once i did that it was like okay
i've solved my my puzzle or my riddle to
a degree and then it was just like well
what foods fit within that
which uh you know now that i've been
doing this for 10 years i have had
the opportunity to go everything from
almost
plant-based i've never done strict vegan
like low-carb or
keto to like basically all animal
products where
i also haven't done too long a stretch
where i was what
we would call like strict carnivore or
100 carnivore but in like 2019 i spent
the majority of that year at probably
like
between 80 to 90 percent uh animal-based
products and then i've done everything
in between from more of like a 50 50
split between
plant sources and animal sources and and
that sort of stuff so
the thing i found that's pretty
consistent is the for me anyways there's
macronutrient ratios
and then everyone kind of says
preferences or tolerances within that as
to whether i think they're going to lean
closer to animal products or closer to
plant products or you know somewhere in
between
what kind of signs should people watch
out for that they might want to consider
switching their diet to low carb like if
they're an athlete
i hope that's that's that question made
sense
yeah so the few that i get introduced to
the most
is kind of sort of similar to what i had
but there's obviously differences like i
think the big one that stands out for a
lot of people is
like just their their energy swings and
things like that
so if someone is uh saying like i have a
lot of
kind of a roller coaster ride of energy
levels throughout the day
that's one where i've seen folks have a
lot of success on
outside of just myself when they kind of
minimize the carbs it's going to be
a little different in how they do it
i've seen folks just
kind of subtly reduce carbohydrate
intake not as extreme as like a strict
ketogenic diet
to folks who do go straight to ketogenic
diet and they see the most success there
and these folks are the ones i'm
actually the most interested in because
sometimes i'll be working with them and
i'll be like okay i'm going to give this
person a workout
and they're going to wish they had
brought back a little bit of
carbohydrate and then they go and nail
it and i just can't figure out how they
managed to do it but uh yeah so
like that energy level thing i think
consistently throughout the course of
the day is a big one
the one i end up probably dealing with
the most within kind of the groups of
people i'm
traditionally working with is like their
intro race or intra work fueling
so you know we go back to we talked
about before is this person who
like every time they go and race they
find themselves having a digestive issue
they just can hardly stand
to eat enough during a race itself so
when we're looking at from a performance
standpoint for these longer
efforts if you can't eat enough
carbohydrate to defend your muscle
glycogen
we need to improve your fat oxidation
rates one way or the other
so that's another big sign is uh um
what is it like what is your racing and
your long run
like consistency looking like from a
digestive standpoint
which feeds into their energy level too
because like if you can't get enough
carbohydrate in during a race and you're
dependent on that
there's going to be a point where you
hit like a spot where you're just
you're going to be you call like a death
march essentially where you're running
way slower than what you
feel you're capable of the back part of
your race is much slower than the first
half of your race and
you know that sort of stuff so those are
some big ones
um yeah so and those are the ones i
typically see the most i'm working
mostly with endurance athletes
when when it comes to more just like
folks who are just interested in
low-carb ketogenic diet i think like
you know those those branch like the
spectrum of experiences too
and i think the one i'm the most
interested in that i don't know like
if we know exactly what's going on here
is just kind of like the
the psychology or the mental state of it
and
the only thing i can think of with that
is like you know you have like these
experiences where
you're maybe inclined to have a little
bit more of like manic and depressive
episodes that are not like
clinical but just like within like a
normal range but noticeable enough where
it's
inconvenient and like
the low carb seems just to be like a
really good option for a lot of people
to kind of normalize that
and i always wonder if that's why
sometimes you see success with kind of
like some of these carnivore anecdotes
about helping with kind of that sort of
thing because they kind of put them
like if you're carnivore you're almost
by default gonna be
kind of pretty strict ketogenic i guess
you could be eating a ton of protein and
maybe
sidestep that to a degree but my guess
is even though it's hard
yeah and those people are going to be
probably still within a
therapeutic ketogenic range i would
imagine in most cases
and i wonder too if like that helps kind
of just it keeps if you think of like an
upper end of your emotions in a lower
end if it just makes
if it tightens that channel a little bit
and that just gives them a little bit
better of an experience from one day to
the next
and yeah so i see a lot of that too just
like just consistent energy levels and
and that sort of thing too
cool okay well zach um
we're nearing the end is there anything
else you want to mention while you're on
here
and also tell people where they can find
you if they want to follow you on
socials
sure and this is totally my fault i kind
of like
distracted us from the original question
but i'd love to share a project i'm
doing uh
this this fall yeah um
you know i said before i've been done
mostly single day ultra marathons so far
i'm going to kind of step away from that
for a bit i actually already have i'm
preparing for it at the moment where i'm
going to run this
project that is called a
transcontinental run
and the route i'm going to take is from
san francisco to new york city so it's
like a 3000
mile track and the way you kind of do it
is
you get an rv and a chase vehicle and a
small crew
and you basically live out of that rv
for however long it takes
the record for it is uh six weeks six
hours
i should say 42 days six hours and 30
minutes
uh which comes out to just over 72 miles
a day by a guy named pete costelnick
um and pete is uh he's the man when it
comes to this like
long haul type stuff he also has done an
event where he went from the
uh keys alaska down to the florida keys
unsupported which means he just pushed a
stroller the whole way
that's like 5 000 miles he averaged over
50 miles a day
so he's got the record for that i've
never done anything remotely close to
this
so like it is enticing to say okay i'm
gonna go after the record
and i think i'm gonna try to but who
knows like
who knows what's gonna happen in like
that time frame as to whether
you know i'm good at that or not or if
it's something my body will be
receptive to or not but my main draw for
that is uh
there's an organization called fight for
the forgotten that a guy named justin
wren
started and he has done a lot of work
with kind of identifying people who
essentially
aren't even at square one in terms of
being able to kind of progress
and he had identified like the pygmy
tribe over in the congo as one of those
people who
you know when the way i like to kind of
describe it in short is if
the only thing you have time to
accomplish during the day is to acquire
clean drinking water
you're you're at square zero because
you're just making sure your basic needs
get met versus
having the extra free time to you know
actually like you know
focus on like development or any type of
progress
so yeah what he did for them was he
started like raising money raising
awareness to build wells so that
essentially once you can build wells you
free up which ends up usually being the
females in the group who are going to
acquire
gather a lot of the water now you have
like
that half of your group or your
population
kind of liberated with more free time to
do other things like maybe it's starting
to develop farming building
more permanent structures and kind of
getting that momentum going or getting
from
square zero to square one and justin's
really big about that he's like let's
get them to square one so that they can
they can progress versus getting
chronically stuck at the spot where they
can't start
uh so when he told me that's an amazing
initiative
yeah i mean he's branched it out too i
mean justin's just got an incredible
backstory i mean he was like severely
bullied and
in in school when he was younger and he
like kind of internalized it to the
point where he became like a world-class
wrestler
uh became an mma fighter and the thing
that's super compelling to me is like
as soon as he started really getting
success as an athlete he could have just
leaned into that and then continued to
be world class but
he he basically like compromised a huge
portion of his competitive career to
start these initiatives he's had like
you know malaria multiple times he's
had all sorts of different issues from
going over to help out the pygmy tribe
and
do that sort of stuff so he's got a lot
of cool ideas and initiatives to
that he wants to add on to this so i
want to help him raise awareness to his
cause and try to put a little bit of
spotlight on him for that so
the purpose of the trip is going to be
to raise awareness for
for fight for the forgotten and uh and
that and that's kind of
the main main the main initiative and if
if a fast pace comes with it then that's
even better
that's so nice that made all the hair on
my arms stand up
that's so nice uh how can people find
out more about this initiative and when
are you planning on doing it
yeah so it's gonna be we're targeting a
september first start date
uh it's kind of weird like when you
think about going across the country
you're dealing
with a lot of like variability with
weather and stuff and from
what i've been able to research if you
start in september you can kind of make
it over the sierras
and get through colorado before like the
real bad storms hit
but you can get to the east coast before
it's the dead of winter
uh so i'm going to start probably around
september 1st
uh to find information on it i'm going
to start putting more stuff on my
website at zacbitter.com
and links to like things like that we're
going to do what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do like a big raffle before the
start
where we're gonna put up like a bunch of
stuff from my sponsors from companies
that want to contribute
and uh start to kind of raise awareness
and raise money kind of in the lead up
to it and i'll have a link to that on my
website uh
in the next week or so um i'm gonna be
doing some live streaming while i'm out
there to try to let people kind of
follow along with it so
my instagram account is gonna lean on
pretty heavily with that one that's just
at zac bitter
i'm gonna try to go live a couple times
or a few times a day and just check in
to show people what it's like when i'm
feeling the best and when i'm feeling my
worst
so you might get happy zach or grumpy
zach depending on
where i am on the journey but uh i think
it'll be fun to kind of showcase that
and
just really let people kind of get a
little bit of an inside look at
what this type of stuff it kind of
involves in these multi-day long-haul
ultra marathon type things as well as
uh you know bring a little bit of a
spotlight to fight for the forgotten if
we can
that's so nice okay well thank you zach
very much for coming on it was nice
talking to you again
that was interesting yeah i know
absolutely michaela it's been
fun to follow your journey and listen to
your podcast i caught your your jp
interview
uh last night before this one and i
thought that was hilarious
yeah he's pretty funny i like him that
was a fun one
okay well good luck good luck with your
insane run
that's a good great cause i'll share it
around socials that's fun that should be
interesting
well thanks a bunch it was uh was it
great to chat michaela
you